Donald Trump in the midst of a failed
first six months in the White House and
endless scandals and investigations and
in the midst of considering whether he
can pardon himself and his family from
crimes they might have committed took to
Twitter this morning to announce that
transgender people will no longer be
allowed in the military maybe a play to
his base may be an attempt to distract
he was uh he announced this in a three
tweet series where he said quote after
consultation with my generals and
military experts please be advised that
the United States government will not
accept or allow transgender individuals
to serve in any capacity in the US
military our military must be focused on
decisive and overwhelming victory and
cannot be burdened with the tremendous
medical costs and disruption that
transgenders in the military that
transgender in the military would entail
thank you how does a transgender person
in the military prevent decisive
victories I wonder nicely timed little
distraction from the bills in the House
and Senate that might lead to 10% of the
country's population losing their health
insurance how does this make any sense
right I mean Trump talked during the
campaign about how he would be a friend
to the LGBT community and it's strange
to remember that back in 1999 Trump was
at the forefront of arguing that gay
Americans should be allowed to serve I
wonder if it's a play to distract the
Obama administration had decided last
year to allow trans people to serve
openly in the military last month
defense secretary James Madison a the
recruitment of transgender people by six
months and this is really not a big deal
in the sense that Trump's making it out
to be the independent RAND Corporation
did a big study into transgender members
of the military it estimates that
there's twenty four hundred and fifty
transgender individuals in the military
out of 1.2 million active duty service
members that's 0.2% the national average
of transgender individuals is estimated
at 0.6% it sort of makes sense right
there's
certainly some self-selection bias the
military has not looked at as a
particularly friendly place to
transgender individuals so it would make
sense that the trans population in the
military would be lower than the trans
population of the United States at large
but how are you going to do this right
how do you enforce it because once
somebody has a biological sex and once
they have a gender identity and they're
in the military unless someone is
requesting military medical coverage for
transitioning how are you going to
figure out who's transgender are you
going to start doing a genitalia tag
like how are you going to go and figure
out okay here's our two thousand four
hundred and fifty transgender
servicemembers now we're kicking them
out I don't get how you even do it aside
from the fact that it makes no sense
they probably don't know themselves and
I think that's the whole point here
because this isn't really about saving
money or national security it's all
about playing to his base and I think we
see that by the fact that he laid that
out in tweets
is anyone else sort of tired of national
policy being announced by Twitter I'm
kind of getting a little tired of it I
don't know about you and the real
question with regard to the trans
community in the military is if you're
qualified to serve shouldn't you just be
allowed to serve Trump should really
look at Israel actually where there are
openly transgender soldiers everything
is fine there have been high-ranking gay
and lesbian members of the Israeli
military for a very long time it's been
no big deal and the this is some
combination of bad policy to appeal to
the most extreme of the Trump base while
distracting from the constant and
endless scandals that Trump finds
himself wrapped up in and I don't know
you know it's if there were questions
this morning about whether the Pentagon
even knew this was coming
maybe not to his generals but he said he
kind of not large it apparently he
consulted with James Madison
doesn't tell us like the James Madison I
dia what does it mean to consult with
and a few generals were actually if
retired generals were asked about this
they said consulting with is a very
vague term we don't really know what
that means is there's sort of an
implication that the generals agree with
this but we don't
really know that the whole profession of
consulting is very big in and of itself
well that's another story